so but you're also
lest i forget to mention you've also
mentored
some of the biggest names of computer
vision computer science and ai today
uh there's so many questions i could ask
but really is
what what is it how did you do it what
does it take to be
a good mentor what does it take to be a
good guide
yeah i i think what i feel i've been
lucky to have
had very very smart and hardworking and
creative students
i think some part of the credit just
belongs to
being at berkeley i think those of us
who are at top
universities are blessed because we have
very very smart and capable students
coming on
knocking on our door so so i have to be
humble enough to acknowledge that
but what have i added i think i have
added something
what i have added is uh i think
what i've always tried to teach them is
a sense of
picking the right problems so
i think that in science in the short run
success is always based on
technical competence you're you know
you're quick with math
or you are whatever i mean there's
certain technical capabilities which
make for
short-range progress long-range progress
is really determined by asking the right
questions
and focusing on the right problems and
i feel that what i've been able to
bring to the table in terms of advising
these students
is some sense of taste
of what are good problems what are
problems that are worth attacking now as
opposed to waiting
10 years what's a good problem if you
could summarize
if is that possible to even summarize
like what what's your sense of a good
problem
i i think i think i have a sense of what
is a good problem which is
uh there is a british scientist uh in
fact he won a nobel prize
peter medover who has a a book on
on this and uh basically he calls
it the research is the art of the
soluble
so we need to sort of find problems
which
are which are not yet solved
but which are approachable and he sort
of refers to this sense that there is
this problem which isn't
quite solved yet but it has a soft
underbelly
there is some place where you can you
know
spear the beast yes and having that
intuition that this problem is ripe is
is a good
thing because otherwise you can just
beat your head and not make progress
so i think that is that is important so
if
if i have that and if i can convey that
to students
it's not just that they do great
research while they're working with me
but that they continue to do great
research so in a sense i'm proud of my
students
and their achievements and their great
research even
20 years after they've seized being my
student
so it's in part developing helping them
develop that sense that a problem
is not yet solved but it's solvable
correct
the other thing which i have which i i
think i bring to the table uh
is i is a certain intellectual breadth
i i've spent a fair amount of time
studying
psychology neuroscience relevant areas
of applied math and so forth
so i can probably help them see some
connections
to disparate things which uh
they might not have otherwise so
so the smart students coming into
berkeley can be
very deep in the sense they can think
very deeply meaning very
hard down one particular path but
uh where i could help them is the
the shallow breadth but
where is they would have the the narrow
depth
and uh but that's that's of some value
well it was beautifully refreshing just
to hear you
naturally jump to psychology back to
computer science and this conversation
back and forth i mean that
that's uh that's actually a rare quality
and i think it's
certainly for students empowering to
think about problems in a new way
you